[Music]
absolutely
hi Lana thank you so much for coming in
I'm detective Snipes
this is detective Carrie we are
currently investigating the murder of
Steven Calvary that's like the saddest
thing to ever happen in history right
yeah sure is
so from what we're told your date to
stay in date did we broke up the last
week
it's a crazy long story but basically he
cheated on me with the ugliest [ __ ] in
America she's like literally a dog he
chewed on you were picking on can you
tell us where you were the night of
August 20th don't judge me but I was at
Burger King I hadn't eaten in like a
year you think you hadn't eaten in a
year you'll be dead if you didn't eat in
the year their story's not enough people
got to eat checker says it you gotta eat
so you're at Burger King eating my night
was Steven there
oh no when was the last time you saw
Steven oh I have things dear in like 100
years you said you broke up with him
last week though I know last week is not
100 years 100 years 100 years do you
remember the last thing you saw him
doing any person he might have been with
yes he was in a fight with like the
tallest man in the world he was in a
fight with salt and Kazan who saw him
Hasan's the tallest man in the world
2007 in its book what is it just me I'm
the only one who follows that focus on
do you remember what this tall man
looked like yes she was very old how old
like a million years old cut it cut it a
part of it
okay Lana we need some real numbers from
you now there's a murderer out there and
you can help us bring them in now on the
night of the fight with this older tall
man do you remember where that was over
on Oak Street in front of one of the
grossest or warehouses with like 50 okay
which was odd I said it's a number a big
number by the number look up all blue
trucks in the area warehouses garages
anything anything else you remember
don't ask me what I was doing there if
there's someone else there we need to
talk to him just Jimmy live in the city
yes where put the bajillion miles away
damn it I can't do this anymore I had
eaten like 50 burgers and I remember
this because Tiffany who's joking man I
turned into Kevin James and I like
literally diet if you ate 50 burgers you
would actually literally be dead right
now you're not telling us the truth
what's really going on huh who's Kevin
James